we called it the traveller and it's  arrival changed us forever great cities  were burnt on Mars and Venus mercury  became a garden world human lifespan  tripled it was a time of miracles we  stared out at the galaxy and knew that  it was our destiny to walk in the light  of other stars but the traveller had an  enemy a darkness which had hunted it for  eons across the black gulfs of space  centuries after our golden age began  this darkness found us  and that was the end of everything that  is clincial I found you  we've always known the darkness would  return to finish what it started  to take our home  that's why I've been looking  for centuries there are only a few of  you who carry the light of the traveler  who have the strength to fight the  darkness  I'm not going to lies you Guardian you  are Earth's last hope  if you fail  everything humans have ever  we'll be gone forever  no pressure